from Spain to Siberia the world is
experiencing record-shattering heat
India suffered its hottest March in more
than 100 years the heart of England
today hotter than the Caribbean and
Western Sahara heart made history again
today
and as the Mercury Rises so too does the
death toll Hospital admissions Rising a
deadly sign of what's to come the body
can't cool down anymore at all the heat
wave turning deadly now it starts to
cook from the inside out
what turns a hot day into a heat wave
and how is that process being affected
by climate change
what counts as a heat wave depends on
where you are in the world
Heat Wave is really not a very
well-defined term when you have
temperature that's a bit over a good bit
over what's normal for that time of year
for a persistent period of time someone
somewhere will be defining that as a
heat wave
in the UK a heat wave can be declared
after three days of more than between 25
and 28 degrees depending on the region
in New York it needs to be at least
three days of 32 degrees or above
while on the Indian Plains a heat wave
can be declared when temperatures are
above 40 degrees and a 4.5 degrees
higher than typical for two days
heat waves are a normal part of the
weather system but how do they form
one factor at the heart of many heat
waves is high pressure
the atmosphere is a sea of air and if
there's a particularly large amount of
air piled up over a particular place
then the air pressure goes up and it
becomes high pressure
areas of high pressure are known as
anticyclones
large slowly rotating masses of air
blowing in a clockwise Direction in the
northern hemisphere
as air moves away from the high pressure
center at ground level air from above
moves down to take its place
the air sinking down is actually heating
up because it's being compressed same
way that a bicycle pump gets hot when
you pump it and that's not only making
the place hotter it's also stopping the
processes by which that place would
normally cool itself down which would be
by having like convective air rising and
clouds forming
in mid-latitude places such as the UK
and America the polar front jet stream
determines where high pressure will
occur
it's a core of very strong winds blowing
from west to east 8 to 11 kilometers
above the Earth's surface
people who take aircraft across the
Atlantic will know that it's often a
good bit quicker if you're coming from
America to Europe than if you're
fighting the jet stream going the other
way
the jet stream doesn't move in a
straight line but meanders Around the
World areas of low pressure sit in the
troughs
and areas of high pressure form in The
Ridges
when the twists and turns of the jet
stream are particularly Amplified
these lows and highs become slow moving
when a high ends up getting stuck in one
place it's known as a block
these can persist for weeks or even
months when you've got one of these
blocking systems working the rest of the
weather basically try has to either stop
or work its way around it
um and that means you get this like eye
of stability uh where the where the
block happens that's where you get the
really nasty heat waves
the heat can become self-perpetuating
when the sun comes down on a summer's
day quite a lot of its energy is spent
on evaporating water in soil moisture or
food plants as heat goes on day after
day you start running out of soil
moisture and that heat which used to go
into this latent heat of evaporating
water just sticks there and heats things
up
this process is Amplified when the
sinking air of the anticyclone traps the
heat in like the lid of a pot
creating what's sometimes known as a
heat Dome
it becomes this sort of weight of
Oppression that that can't shift itself
that can't be undermined
this process unfolded in the 2021 heat
wave in the Pacific Northwest of America
and Canada
Vancouver a city baking yet again
tonight in a record-smashing heat wave
one that's being called not just
historic but dangerous
the heat wave exceeded National maximum
temperatures day after day after day
setting a new record of 49.6 degrees
Celsius
a political letter eventually actually
caught fire
the heat wave of left scientists
basically gobsmacked they really hadn't
anticipated that anything like that
would come about
waves broke records in every continent
in 2022 but it's when countries are
unprepared that temperatures can be
deadly
between 2000 and 2019 South Asia saw
over a hundred and ten thousand
heat-related excess deaths a year and in
America heat is responsible for more
deaths than tornadoes
hurricanes or floods
the heat waves don't have the drama of
many other big weather events however
they do kill a lot of people and that's
why they're sometimes called the hidden
Killers or the Unseen killers
in some climates like India heat and
humidity can be a lethal combination
humans like Landscapes cool down through
evaporation we sweat and the sweat
evaporates and that takes away heat if
the humidity in the air is high then
that's a less efficient way of cooling
yourself down so the higher the humidity
in a given temperature the hotter you
will actually feel
a so-called wet bulb temperature
measures heat stress providing an
indication of the danger to human life
it's measured by wrapping an old-school
mercury thermometer in a damp cloth
if you have a wet bulb temperature above
about 35 degrees Celsius that's to say
above body temperature the body can't
cool down anymore at all and it starts
to cook from the inside out
even young healthy people will die after
about six hours in this heat and
humidity
wet bulk temperatures are on the rise
many countries have already hit a wet
bulb temperature of 31 degrees
and a few weather stations in South Asia
the Persian Gulf and the Southwest coast
of North America have recorded wet bulb
temperatures close to or above 35
degrees Celsius for short periods
hello I'm Elliot I work with Economist
films if you'd like to read more of our
coverage of extreme weather why not take
out a subscription to The Economist
you'll receive daily and weekly analysis
of global Affairs you can read us online
in the app or listen to the audio
Edition
for the best offer click the link
spiking temperatures can be unbearable
but aren't always the direct cause of
fatalities
all around the world excessive heat will
make it harder for people to breathe and
it will put stress on their circulatory
systems this is particularly bad for
people who are old or people who have
underlying conditions
and it's not always hot days that are
the deadliest
so-called tropical Knights where the
temperature doesn't drop below 20
degrees Celsius but on the rise in many
countries
it's not entirely clear why this is
associated with mortality but it is
something about the very disturbed sleep
that people get during such events does
seem to make it more likely that some of
them will die
cold water
bananas oranges incredibly even simple
adaptations can save lives
but being prepared is
most places where there has been an
unexpected lethal horrible Heat Wave
afterwards work out what they should
have done and try to put into place
policies habits that would make things
better next time the trick is to learn
the lessons before you get the heat wave
something France realized when a heat
wave in 2003 killed 14 000.
one of the reasons why it was
particularly lethal was that France just
hadn't seen itself as the sort of place
that has heat waves like that
there were a lot of lessons learned in
France both personally and
institutionally one of them was that you
need to check in on people if you have
any worries about them another is that
you need to find a way to bring people
especially elderly people people in poor
housing to places which were cooled down
School gyms for example that turns out
to be something that works very well
[Music]
unless they adapt now countries yet to
experience the most extreme heat are
going to be particularly susceptible
the sort of areas that people worry
about where heat waves have historically
not been seen that much but where they
could do an awful lot of damage is
Afghanistan other parts of Central Asia
and parts of Central America as well
adaptation will be ever more important
as climate change continues to increase
atmospheric temperatures
often the role of climate change in
extreme weather is a bit subtle a bit
this a bit that if you make the planet
hotter you are going to make the heat
waves hotter
and a relatively new area of science is
key to understanding the impact
the idea of weather attribution is to
work out how much more likely a given
event that's just been seen is because
of the global warming compared to How
likely it would have been without that
global warming
pioneering attribution study focused on
the 2003 heat waves in Europe
responsible for 70 000 deaths
the researchers involved concluded that
heat waves like the 2003 Heatwave were
now roughly twice as likely as they had
been in the pre-climate change world
evidence has piled up since in Siberia
in 2020 temperatures reached 38 degrees
Celsius the highest ever recorded north
of the Arctic Circle
researchers say climate change made this
heat wave 600 times more likely
you're basically saying that this is
whether that you would never see without
climate change
the mechanism is simple greenhouse gas
emissions have pushed up average
atmospheric temperatures by at least one
degree Celsius from pre-industrial
levels
a small shift in the average makes the
really unlikely high temperatures at the
extreme tail much more likely
if the atmosphere continues to warm you
will see heat waves worse than we've
seen historically and you will see them
over larger areas
there are predictions that under some
warming scenarios fairly extreme ones
you could see wet bulb temperatures that
make areas basically unlivable becoming
quite common in a few parts of the world
but scientists don't yet understand how
climate change will affect the
atmospheric circulation patterns that
cause heat waves
the question of whether the odd things
that cause domes of high pressure to
persist over particular places whether
those will become more or less likely
some models say yeah some say no they
contradict each other whatever the
answer humankind needs to act now
even after greenhouse gas levels in the
atmosphere are stabilized and with them
one hopes the climate there'll still be
a lot more heat waves because the
average temperature of the planet will
be higher
governments need to do more to protect
their populations not just National
governments but also City governments
local governments at the same time
people need to understand the risks so
that they can protect themselves and
crucially each other
I'm Oliver Morton I'm a senior editor at
The Economist
for more of our coverage of extreme
weather and climate change please click
on the link
and also if you want more of this please
subscribe and as you do so already in
which case many thanks
[Music]